My name's Tim.
I'm the principal rural fire officer for the
district.
Waimakariri District that is.
The fire season is finally heating up after
a wet spring.
Under these hot, dry, windy conditions it's
very easy for a fire to get out of control.
If you are found responsible for a fire such as this, you could well be held liable and
wear the costs of containing and extinguishing that fire.
So please, think before light.
Here are some tips, that you might think about
before you light a fire.
The Waimakariri District is now under a restricted
fire season.
This means that no fires in the open are to
be lit without a permit.
Check out the video linked below for more
information.
If you're on a lifestyle block or farm, check
the weather forecast before lighting.
Far too many fires last year were foolishly
started when strong winds were predicted.
Keep a hose nearby, charged and ready for
immediate use.
And keep ten to thirty metres clearance around
buildings and outhouses.
Remember the more you feed it, the bigger
a fire grows.
Don't mess around with fire, because when
it gets out of control, things go very bad,
very fast.
Just because it's no longer smoking, it doesn't
mean it's out.
Fires can smoulder for months, so before leaving,
check by putting your hand in the ashes.
If the ashes are still warm, open it up, put
a hose in it and wet it down thoroughly.
We don't want a repeat of previous year's
mistakes,  so to ensure we all have a great summer
please, think before you light.
For more information about the restricted
fire season and applying for a permit, please
visit waimakariri.govt.nz